I think sometimes there's a lot of like
judgment
kendall Jenner took full control of the
narrative around her dating rumors
specifically a tweet and tick-tock video
commenting on her alleged relationships
with NBA stars well it was also
seemingly in response to Kendall being
spotted in Arizona on Wednesday with
Devin Booker a player for the Phoenix
Suns in 2018 he also happened to be
romantically linked to Kylie Jenner's
former best friend Jordan woods
one user captioned this video NBA
players passing around kendall Jenner
another replied maybe she's passing them
around which prompted Kendall herself to
enter the conversation writing they act
like I'm not in full control of where I
throw this couch I promise I'll try my
best
the colorful clap back was followed by
sister Kylie Jenner joining the fun
tweeting LMFAO tweet of the Year kendall
explained to et in 2015 why she likes to
keep her dating life private
it's not always easy but I don't know I
just kind of I like to keep my private
life pretty private so I try my best but
at the same time I don't I don't like to
let being seen out in public with
someone like affect my everyday life
like if I want to go grab a smoothie
with a friend who's a male I'm not gonna
like let the paparazzi like stop me from
doing that and living my life and just
being a normal person's
[Music]